something else I want to address is you
are in post or you're almost done with
boss love done which is I'm so excited
to see this thing yeah what can you do
for people that don't know what the
movie is about what can you say I can
say it's basically like you know
Groundhog Day and diehard had a child
it's you know listen it's it's kind of
you know smells like source code the
Gyllenhaal thing or like edge of
tomorrow it's really not because you
know this version of the quote-unquote
you know the repeating day like the kind
of the endless death loop day it's not
somebody who oh my god what's happening
me it's somebody who it's had to happen
to one hundred forty times so when you
meet Frank grillers character the
beginning he's already bored stiff with
what's going on to the point where he
just goes to the same restaurant every
day and gets drunk and ways to get
killed
and so that's kind of the point of
departure for boss level and I could say
Hannah Hart and Ben has seen it I don't
think that I've done with all due
respect to the gray and all the respect
to narc and so on I don't I think this
is the best film I've done it's
fantastic because it's it's the it is
the embodiment in orders it's like
somewhere between the grand smokin aces
only with no cynicism whatsoever it's
very much me softening in my old age I
think but it's but it's I think it's a
wand meows pros who shot el Chicano
friends shot bostonia our dear friend
the DP said the best quote about it I
heard about boss oh it's funny as hell
until it's not and then it's even better
so I think that's a wonderful way of
looking at the film for for people that
when are people gonna see this thing you
know what I'm having a big two days
before el Chicano opens I'm having a
huge refers recruited screening so I
will report back thusly
about where we're gonna be and what
we're gonna be doing how I last time I
spoke to Frank was maybe for real man
yeah other stuff what's coming up for
war party in terms of what you guys are
working
we're got we've got the raid the remake
of the raid which we hope we start very
good talk to you about this for at least
yeah five or six days yeah that's that's
gonna be exactly that's gonna be
something that we're hopefully we're
gonna be in prep in the next
next hopefully the next few weeks oh
this is actually because well I say that
and then you never know because it's
it's moviemaking so it's it's about this
for real like three years sometimes the
perennials don't bloom like you wanted
right you know so so that's it looks
like it's next we have this thing called
wildfire which is great it's kind of
female kind of female first blood and
the lead character only says one word
the whole movie which I'm pretty excited
about is great I won't ruin you what the
word is but she says one word I'm gonna
say [ __ ] no I wish and then I did this
thing I wrote the spec called thorn
which I'm really really fired up about
which I will hopefully do right after
the raid maybe as soon as the end of the
year maybe the top of 2020 with the raid
and then they'll Chicano sequel that's
right yeah of course yeah with the raid
how how you've been in pre-production on
this if you will for a while how has it
changed during the process and what is
the version that you are looking forward
to for people to see I think the version
that we have again Gareth was wonderful
about kind of communicating to Frank and
I list I don't want you you know you
guys do your version I'm excited to see
whatever you guys are gonna do with it
and I also think that listen you know
smokin aces is not dissimilar from the
rain that came out six years earlier
about guys attacking you know a
structure and trying to remove a guy
from the penthouse that's kind of so I
was like this is ultimately kind of
familiar territory but I think where we
differ is you meet Frank's character
having just rotated back from a really
really brutal operation like Special
Forces and he's got you know soft tissue
damage his hands and and his rotator
cuff is blown out he's got you know they
take fluid off of lives left knee and
fluid off his right knee and the doctors
basically tell him listen you're toying
with the real that you're at the razor's
edge of PTSD and you need three months
of just nothing R&R because you're
beer-beer jacked up and in that space he
gets the message that his brother we
thought had been dead for four years is
actually alive and working for a very
bad guy in Caracas and in 18 hours
they're gonna kill his brother
these forces are gonna descend and
murder the bad guy and
the brothers so do you want to go and
get your brother who you think who you
thought is dead and do you want that
opportunity so that's the that's the
that's the where we start
that's an awesome start yeah the my
other my last thing on the raid is and I
think I've asked you this in the past
but it's it's so true the raid the
action set-pieces in that movie are so
ridiculous they're they're insane yeah
they accomplished yeah with I don't want
to talk about how they accomplished it
it's crazy how they what they did use it
literally using dead bodies in Jakarta
to do this I mean yeah it's crazy what
they did yeah but there's gonna be that
comparison in terms of whatever you do
there's gonna be a camaris into the
action of that raid the action you're
yeah what we're not when people ask me
to describe what we're gonna do action
wise I say I want it I want the entire
movie to feel like the knife fight
between Adam Goldberg and the German in
Saving Private Ryan everything like the
whole Aldi all that stuff to feel that
because what I do think that will differ
this from is that there has to be in
every I think great action film there's
always an emotional quotient that you're
dealing with there's always you know if
John McClane isn't walking over glass
with bare feet and you know that his
wife Sarah you know he's got a dog you
don't really care as much as you know
you really want that guy to win because
you know what's at stake try you have to
have a sense of stakes and I think I
talked about this and I was talking a
friend of mice you know for all of the
the the tremendous excess of those last
two Matrix films which I enjoyed the
hell out of them they never kind of got
to the to the great tension of just
canneries trying to answer a phone at
the end of the movie you know what I
mean like there was great paint those
those great kind of sense about oh god
he's is he gonna make is gonna make it
and I think we get the spectacle of it I
think becomes outweighs what's really
the heart and soul of it and I think
that's what you have to remember is that
you got to have that attached you know
it's the comparison I talked about
between Lord of the Rings in The Hobbit
Lord of the Rings is about the end of
the world it is literally the
annihilation of everything the Hobbit is
these people just wanting to get gold
right this
you know or in John wick you know the
what happens with the dog the rest of
the movie I am rooting for you know
Keanu to destroy people yeah yeah you
know here absolutely out what happened
in the best of those revenge kind of
genre films you have that inherent like
you want it to happen because because
you need this you know we need that
catharsis it's the same thing in any I
said in any good action movie that
you'll see will find that commonality